la mort tragique d'une cycliste la
semaine dernière sous un viaduc de la
rue saint denis à relance évidemment le
débat sur la sécurité la cohabitation
vélo auto et mais si la solution était
port en dessous peut-être au-dessus des
viaducs avec des passages à niveau
pourquoi pas voyez ce reportage fort
intéressant de jean-sébastien cloutier
chaque jour de semaine
mr et mme inoue son fils théo traverse
la voie ferrée du canadien pacifique qui
sépare leur maison de la garderie mista
yagan une demi-heure par jour en prenant
le raccourci et elle évite
volontairement les tunnels papineau et
de lorimier endroit peu éclairé dit elle
et où les véhicules roulent vite
des fois je me sens obligé d'apprendre
la voit qu'ils aiment la moins dangereux
et moi je trouve qui est ici c'est la
choix consciente d'être dans
l'illégalité
elle est devenue porte parole d'un
regroupement de citoyens qui demandent
au canadien pacific d'installer des
passages à niveau pour piétons et
cyclistes sur sa voie ferrée comme ici à
boucherville sur la voie du cn la ville
est séparé par une demi-douzaine de ses
passages qui coûte quelques dizaines de
milliers de dollars chacun a aménagé un
léger infrastructures et un petit porte
acquis au s'ouvre et qui se referme
anthony un train qui part ça enlève les
piétons et les cyclistes dévié dicte ça
fait plus de vingt ans que la même
demande est faite au canadien pacifique
qui n'a jamais répondu aux citoyens ont
tort leur table à l'autre côté nous
écoute pas mais la ville s'est mise à
faire pression et l'eau si elle commet
d'une étude en 2012 qui conclut qu'il
faudrait c'est ce passage sur la voie du
cp de l'est du plateau jusqu'à en sic de
seraient près de la rue saint denis où
ils étaient nombreux hier à traverser
illégalement l'étudier avait d'ailleurs
recensé près de 400 personnes en une
seule journée
la mort tragique de la cycliste heurté
par un camion le 28 avril sous le viaduc
de la rue saint denis a donc relancé le
débat
c'est à laver on avait eu un passage à
niveau ici pour vrai peut-être
la femme aurait pu traverser ici au lieu
du prend le biais d'autres de saint
denis
joint au téléphone le porte parole du
canadien pacifique s'est contenté de
dire que l'entreprise avait des
inquiétudes sur la sécurité des piétons
avec un tel projet le processus de
médiation est en cours avec la ville
je sais pas si vous parlez de médiation
donc ça pourrait évoluer au cours des
prochaines semaines les prochains jours
après plusieurs mois d'attenté la ville
de montréal connaît enfin les dates de
ces deux journées de médiation avec le
canadien pacifique ça auront lieu les 28
et 29 mai prochains
donc ici a pas d'entente avec le
médiateur c'est un arbitre fédéral qui
éventuellement tranchera pas très sain
remonte à juin dernier pour avoir cette
demande de la ville d'avoir une
médiation
écoutez la ville se plaint de l'attitude
du canadien pacifique dans ce dossier
depuis des années elle affirme que le cp
ne fait que dire non catégoriquement
cette demande de nouveaux passages à
niveau ne se gênent pas d'ailleurs la
ville pour critiquer de façon générale
le cp avec qui c'est plus difficile
d'avoir des négociations qu'avec par
exemple le cn à montréal je vous laisse
écouter le responsable des transports à
la ville
aref salem qui lui tient beaucoup à six
nouveaux passages à niveau entre autres
ici sur le plateau mont royal
actuellement c'est juste ils ne veulent
rien savoir
parce que c'est pas sécuritaire donc le
message est clair il est court et c'est
pas sécuritaire ce n'est pas vrai que ce
n'est pas sécuritaire on peut travailler
à le rendre sécuritaire et il y a
actuellement partout dans la ville de
montréal il y à des passages à niveau
qui sont sécurisées
c'est très important qu'il y ait ces
passages à niveau là de 1,7 sont des
passages qui
où les gens passent de toute façon
aujourd'hui les gens il
ils ont un besoin de passer donc ils
passent on dit qu'il fasse une façon
illégale actuellement donc pourquoi pas
ne pas légaliser la chose et la rendre
sécuritaire alors on rappelle qu'ils
passent grosso modo une douzaine un demi
douzaine de trains par jour sur cette
voie du canadien pacifique qui va
jusqu'au port de montréal et au cours
des dernières années les employés du cp
qui en avait marre de toujours réparer
les brèches créées par les gens dans la
clôture ont décidé plutôt d'installer un
inspecteur surtout dans le secteur où je
me trouve près de la rue saint denis si
ce soit un inspecteur donc qui donnent
des contraventions 246 dollars rien de
moins
aux contrevenantes qui traverse la voie
ferrée à pied ou en vélo et vous en avez
montré plusieurs des de ses piétons
cette femme b qui va reconduire son
enfant ce qui est ce qui ce qu'il faut
souligner encore une fois jean-sébastien
c'est que les gens du cp d'abord ya pas
de porte parole ici à montréal on vous
avait pu parler au téléphone mais c'est
compliqué et ça je pense ça fait 20 ans
qu'on dénonce la situation
toute la voie ferrée à a une emprise
importante sur l'île sur la ville alors
à suivre on suit ça pour vous merci au
revoir